hi there steve kaufman
um i want to talk about vocabulary
because you know sometimes people say to
me well
uh you've heard of this uh elevator
statement you know if you had to
summarize in 20 seconds
what is link you know or
how does one learn languages
and it suddenly dawned on me that the
short statement of what language
learning is
is the following
learn the words and phrases of the
language
learn what they mean
and learn how they sound
that is in essence language learning
vocabulary
is by far in my view the most important
element of language learning
because
first of all as i pointed out earlier
while
a few thousand words may account for 80
percent of most
language contexts the remaining 20 which
has the key words to the meaning of the
passage
these
this remaining 20
requires a lot of words many of which
are relatively rare and
when we are in a situation where we
don't understand it's be very often
because we don't know
the words
now i posted a video in french
where i talked about
the subjunctive
and i said that i had heard that in the
canadian
public service
where people get a premium for speaking
french anglophones
francophones get a premium for speaking
english
but
anglophones get a premium for speaking
french and in their test to see if they
qualify for this premium they are tested
on the subjunctive
and in the subjunctive it's like in
english i wish i were is the subjunctive
form in english which we don't use very
much most people say i wish i was
but in french and other latin languages
or romance languages the subjunctive is
alive and well
but
learners especially anglophone learners
often don't quite pick up on the
subjunctive
uh in english if i say i wish i was
instead of i wish i were
everybody understands there is no
loss of understanding
uh through not using the subjunctive
so i said you know to fail people or to
deny them their bilingual premium
because they can't
use the subjunctive correctly to me is
just plain
silly in other words the subjunctive
really doesn't matter
if our main objective is communication
and i had a comment they were saying
well the subjunctive is important a
civil servant you know a public servant
should demonstrate you know a high level
of competence in the language
and i say
nonsense
the only thing that matters is the
ability to communicate and when it comes
to communication in the workplace
the number one thing is to understand
what's going on first and foremost
thereafter to get your meaning across
but we have had prime ministers in
canada
anglophones who spoke poor french
francophones who spoke poor english they
were still able to give speeches and get
their meaning across
if barack obama arrived in paris and sat
in on a meeting where everything took
place in french
and he participated and seemed to
understand exactly what people were
saying and even had some clever things
to say and he got his meaning across
but he didn't use the subjunctive
correctly nobody would mind it wouldn't
matter now if on the other hand someone
doesn't utter a statement without having
the subjunctive
right but doesn't have enough vocabulary
to understand what's going on or to
express themselves that can be a problem
so there is no question in my mind that
vocabulary trumps grammar
uh just as if trump's
accent or pronunciation
people might be jarred a bit if you
um speak english where you make the odd
grammatical mistake or if you have a bit
of an accent but if you have enough
words that a you understand what's being
said
and b you can get your meaning across
you'll make it and if you're a good
communicator in terms of you know all of
the other elements that go into
communication you'll do fine that's not
to say we shouldn't try
to uh to become
you know better in the language to
improve our pronunciation to master all
the fine points for sure but it's not so
important
unless of course you are you know
teaching the language or writing essays
in the language but for most people i
mean why do we learn languages we learn
languages in order to communicate and
that's why
when i speak chinese i try to get my
tones right my tones aren't too bad
actually they improved once i stopped
worrying about them
it's very difficult to get the gender
right all the time in french or german
it's very difficult they get the cases
right all the time in russian or german
but if we spend all our time worrying
about it we end up tongue-tied and we
can't speak so
my emphasis is always on vocabulary
learn the words and phrases of the
language
and if you learn the phrases you'll
start getting some of the grammar right
because it's part of these patterns
these phrases that you're picking up so
learn the words and phrases of the
language learn what they mean and learn
how they sound that's
my take on it and
by all means if one day like i would
love to speak russian without making any
mistakes on my cases but i'm very often
in discussions at link with our tutors
and i know far more words than some of
the other people who are participating
in the discussion who probably speak
more accurately than i do but i
understand exactly what the tutor is
saying in russian and i've got plenty of
words to stumble through my explanation
even with mistakes so
i say
hang the subjunctive
worry about it when you have time but in
the meantime focus in other words if the
uh you know the fairy godmother came up
to me and said you have a choice i can
give you
sufficient vocabulary so that you can
understand
everything you want to read and
everything you hear but you'll mistake
you'll make mistakes in the subjunctive
or i can enable you to be absolutely
correct in your use of the subjunctive
but you will have a very limited
vocabulary which would you prefer
no
question i would rather have the
vocabulary so there you have it thanks
for listening